I really want to start with a sincere
congratulations
um loved the movie and I wish I could
watch part two like tomorrow me too
right sure so I am you and Tom in the
Mission Impossible movies have done
incredible stunts that everyone I mean
we all know Tom does these things
they're incredibly difficult they're
risking his life in terms of all the
stunts you've done that you've worked
with Tom on how would you rank the
difficulty of the stunts for the
missions and how nervous you were
watching Tom do them they all have their
own they all have their own risks uh and
the in and it's not always what you
perceive the risk to be uh for example
the a400 the concern was less that Tom
would fall off the plane then he would
be hit by a rock on the runway or a bird
when we were in midair so there's all
these different factors and variables
that you're constantly thinking about
that could go wrong outside of all the
variables that you've eliminated and the
more the more variables the the scarier
the stunt I think that's that's kind of
to me what makes it terrifying is how
how many different ways Tom could be
killed doing the stunt and the but
they're all knowns they're they're all
things that you've that you've thought
about and can't control
going off that ramp was he was entering
the unknown we had eliminated everything
we possibly could we just didn't know
what would actually happen when he did
it because we couldn't we could in no
way shape or form test or replicate
those conditions anywhere else so when
he went off that ramp we just we didn't
know what was going to happen we didn't
know if the bike would get away from him
we didn't know if a crosswind would
would tangle him up uh and we didn't
know if the Drone would hit him based on
the environment that we were in so once
we called action you just you had to
hold your breath until the the shoot
opened that was pretty terrifying so but
I I do want to bring in all the missions
you've worked on oh okay and so what I'm
curious about is how would you rank
those all the set pieces that you've
worked on like what's your top three or
top five in terms of level of difficulty
and the way how nervous you are before
Tom did them I I would I would say they
probably go in chronological order uh
big only because
when we were doing uh when we were doing
Rogue nation and we were doing the a400
it was really my first time directing
anything like that it was obviously
Tom's first time doing anything like
that uh and everything you're seeing
every movie you're watching is Tom and I
applying our knowledge from the previous
movies into the next one and pushing it
a little bit further so the the the ramp
the motorcycle jump in this film for
example is taking all of the motorcycle
stunts from Rogue Nation taking the base
jumping from
fall out and applying them into the same
stunt they're all just an order of
magnitude scarier if you just follow
them in order each one is each one is
more is more scary for me and more of an
unknown because we're just pushing
ourselves that much further
um and I can tell you there's stuff
coming in eight that is is beyond
anything we've done
um personally for me personally uh the
scariest thing we ever did was the
helicopter chase in Fallout for the
simple fact that I had to be in a
helicopter chasing after Tom so so
there's the added factor of my own life
was at risk when you're watching Tom go
off the bike ramp I'm there I'm
definitely watching my life flash before
my eyes as well as his but I also know
in the event of anything terrible I'm
still going to be there so I would have
to say probably number one scariest most
stressful was the helicopter chase can
fall out just because
I was there so I'm I want to word this
correctly and respectfully to make sure
so but Tom risks his life for real
making these movies yes have you guys
ever had like a conversation or talked
about God forbid
um we we that's that's definitely a A
specter in every single one of those
conversations
um but that's a reality in in in in in
in simple things uh in Jack Reacher a
shot where Rosman Pike was backing out
of a parking spot
with a camera over her shoulder and
revealing Tom standing in front of her
she went to drive away
that's a very dangerous stunt that's an
extremely dangerous stunt because Rosman
Pike who is not an experienced Stunt
Driver could make one simple mistake hit
the accelerator instead of the gas and
that's lights out so we treat everything
the exact same way in the stunt where he
broke his ankle and fall out jumping
from building to building there are a
million variables where something could
go wrong we we have an expression we
repeat all the time which is don't be
careful be competent you you you can't
make these movies without taking risks
and without doing extremely dangerous
things but you could be very very smart
and very very considerate about the way
you do it the other thing that's really
critical whenever we're doing it is I
deputize uh the crew down to camera
operators Focus pullers anyone can yell
cut if you see something wrong you can
stop the movie it's not it's not worth
doing and we don't want a culture where
people are thinking I thought I felt
something was wrong but I didn't think
it was my place to stay to say rather so
there's a there's a huge
um uh there's a there's a huge uh bubble
uh that that everybody is participating
in that everybody is aware of just to
make those things safer but yeah we we
think about that all the time but we
don't uh uh you you don't you you can't
Factor it into your planning it's the
it's that thing of if you're I was
watching a video recently where someone
was saying if you're if you're skiing
through the woods and you're saying
don't hit the trees don't hit the trees
all you're thinking about is the trees
you really have to be thinking stay on
the trail stay on the trail and that's
that's what we do it's just how do you
how do you do it safely just safety
safety safety you know I like talking
about editing and run times and all that
stuff so I'll just bring it in now uh
movies like two and a half hours maybe a
few minutes over how long was your did
you have a much longer cut oh yes yes
very very long it's but that's not
unusual uh I think probably every movie
I've done has been your first assembly
is I don't want to I don't even want you
to say the assembly because everyone
thinks that's the real running time yeah
what was your first like director's cut
that you were like oh this is really
good and I'm showing the studio and this
is good um I never had that
um we always with every cut we knew it
could be better we knew it could be
tighter when we finally screened it
uh for at the the last test audience and
we're happy with the result
um we were about we were about two
minutes longer than we are now and I and
we walked away from it and the studio is
very happy the scores were great uh but
we still knew we had we had issues we
knew we had issues with pace and length
and we and we went back into the editing
room reconfigured the First Act and
ended up taking two minutes out of the
movie which were which were critical and
it can literally be that
that close the difference in two minutes
can make the difference between the
movie feeling you know feeling long or
Feeling Just Right Fallout we had a cut
of the movie that was five minutes
shorter but scored lower it was just it
was cut too tight it couldn't breathe
and um and and we're we're just
absolutely microscopic and surgical
about it in terms of how we get there
but I'd say I'd say where the movie
started to work for me uh because what
you're seeing is the director's cut I
mean that's really how we we look at it
there's not some extended version of the
of the of the movie that I would show
you thinking it was an improvement on it
um where we got into a place where I was
approaching satisfaction it's the
difference of a couple of minutes when
part two is eventually done yeah
um do you want people to watch part one
and part two in one sitting or will you
always wanted like people to take a
break after the first one digest and
come back ideally I will have made a
made two movies that you can watch on
their own or together
um we never want you to have to check
out of the movie you're in to remember
another movie this we did the same thing
with top gun Maverick we've done it with
all of the the missions that we've done
we're not we want to keep you immersed
in the movie that's a that's a big uh
that's a big red line for us how did you
decide where to end the movie on part
one and was it ever going to be
something else
um like you know what I mean
um when the movie was
so long and we couldn't we were too
close to it we couldn't figure out how
to how to cut it down further
we talked about breaking the movie up
and and the problem was there was just
no place for the movie to end the story
was so interconnected that we uh that
was the only time we really discussed
any other kind of ending and that's just
frankly that's exhaustion and not
wanting to confront the reality of we
still have work to do
um the uh the the movie Always ended
where it did we just didn't know what
the ending exactly was it was really
critical for us that when you watch this
movie as part of a two-parter that you
feel satisfied at the end of part one
that that it's not just suddenly ending
and we'll see you later it had to feel
like a complete movie it it had to be a
movie that if part two
didn't exist or we hadn't figured out
what part two was or you had to wait two
years to see the next one you would have
been satisfied with this one I think
that's what we did